>> IN RUSSIA, OBJECTING TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S UNIVISION
UKRAINE CAN COME AT A VERY HIGH
PRICE.
OR, RATHER A VERY LONG
SENTENCE.
KREMLIN CRITIC AND WRITER
KARA-MURZA WAS DETAINED IN
APRIL ON --
TELEVISION APPEARANCES
INCLUDING ONES ON CNN WHERE HE
DENOUNCED PUTIN'S CLAIMS OF A
REGIME OF MURDERERS.
HE IS STILL BEHIND BARS TODAY.
KARA-MURZA AS A POLITICIAN, AND
CONTRIBUTING COLUMNIST OF THE
WASHINGTON POST, HE SUBMITTED
THAT ESSAY THIS WEEK.
HIS LAWYER CARRIED THE TEXT OUT
OF PRISON FOR HIM, AND SENT IT
TO WASHINGTON.
IN THE ESSAY, HE THINKS HIS
WIFE AND SOUL MATE, AFGHANI
OFFERED HER SUPPORT.
AND THIS WEEK I SPOKE WITH HER
ABOUT HER HUSBAND'S ARREST AND
WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN NEXT.
>> MY HUSBAND WAS SENTENCED TO
15 DAYS FOR DISOBEYING A POLICE
ORDER AND SENT --
FOR 15 DAYS.
WE KNEW THAT THIS WAS ONLY THE
BEGINNING WHEN HE STARTED
WRITING.
WE KNEW THAT RUSSIAN
AUTHORITIES WERE USING THIS AS
A PRETEXT TO HOLD HIM.
TO GIVE THEMSELVES TIME TO FIND
SOME MORE SERIOUS ACCUSATIONS
AGAINST HIM.
AND THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT.
HAPPENED MY HUSBAND WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE RELEASED ON
APRIL 26TH, BUT ON APRIL 22ND,
NEW CHARGES WERE INITIATED
AGAINST HIM.
HE WAS CHARGED UNDER NEW LAW.
SO, BASICALLY, BY CALLING THIS
WAR A WAR A PERSON CAN GET
15-YEAR PRISON TEN SENTENCE.
>> WHEN IT WAS PASSED, WHEN I
15 YEARS WAS SENTENCE, DID YOU
AND YOUR HUSBAND TALK ABOUT
MAKING A CHANGE ABOUT NOT
SPEAKING OUT.
WAS THERE A FEAR?
THAT HIS TIME WAS COMING UP?
>> WE'VE ALWAYS KNOWN ABOUT THE
RISKS.
THE RISKS OF ALWAYS BEEN THERE.
BUT THEY WERE VERY TANGIBLE
SINCE 2015, SINCE MY HUSBAND'S
FIRST POISONING.
>> THE POISONING.
>> AND THE MURDER OF BORIS
NEMTSOV.
BUT YES, IT MIGHT BE A
HYPOCRITICAL OF ME TO TRY AND
DISSUADE MY HUSBAND FROM GOING
BACK TO RUSSIA.
THIS IS HIS --
HE BELIEVES IN WHAT HE IS
DOING.
>> YOUR HUSBAND IS ONE WHO HAS
WORN MANY HATS OVER THE YEARS.
A POLITICIAN, AUTHOR, HISTORIAN,
CONTRIBUTING COLUMNIST FOR THE
WASHINGTON POST, TELL US ABOUT
THAT DYNAMIC BETWEEN POLITICIAN
AND JOURNALIST, OR WRITER.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE DON'T
SEE IS OFTEN IN THE UNITED
STATES.
BUT WE DO SEE IT IN OTHER
COUNTRIES.
>> VLADIMIR IS A RENAISSANCE
MAN.
JOURNALISM IS ALWAYS BEEN
IMPORTANT TO HIM BECAUSE THIS
IS A WAY TO --
TO PROVIDE PEOPLE WITH
OBJECTIVE INFORMATION ABOUT
TRUTH.
THIS IS A WAY TO DEFUSE TRUTH,
TO SPEAK ABOUT WHAT IS REALLY
HAPPENING.
SO, JOURNALISM IS ALWAYS BEEN
IMPORTANT TO VLADIMIR.
BUT HE HAS ALWAYS SEEN HIMSELF
AS A POLITICIAN.
>> WHAT ARE YOU TELLING YOUR
THREE CHILDREN ABOUT THEIR
FATHER?
AND ABOUT WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN TO
HIM?
>> I AM TELLING THEM THE TRUTH.
WE HAVE NEVER TRIED TO HIDE THE
TRUTH FROM THE KIDS.
ESPECIALLY NOW, WE HAVE THREE
TEENAGERS IN RESIDENCE, SO IT
IS HARD --
IT WOULD BE HARD TO HIDE THE
TRUTH FROM THEM EVEN IF I
WANTED TO.
THEY ARE ONLINE MORE THAN I
EVER WILL BE, AND THEY KNOW
EVERYTHING THAT IS HAPPENING
AROUND THE WORLD.
THERE ARE OF COURSE VERY
WORRIED FOR THEIR FATHERS
SAFETY, AND THEY WANT HIM HOME.
FOR THEM HE IS NOT A POLITICIAN,
HE IS NOT A JOURNALIST, HE'S
NOT A HISTORIAN, HE IS A DADDY.
I CANNOT IMAGINE HOW HARD AND
FRIGHTENING THIS ALL IS FOR
THEM.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, I THINK
THEY REALIZE WHO THEIR FATHER'S,
BECAUSE THEY KNOW ABOUT HIS
WORK.